có năng lý bằng ABSB, ngày 1 thêm 1 công bố đã triệt phá một đặc mua am sad,
nhằm vào một quan trức cấp cao khi ông dự kênh đến thăm bộ người thân
tánh giới trang Chhoi Khorov, Scourier, Más Kava,
theo ABSB, kêu hoặc này, gió các tất quan tình báo khuyên à điều phối,
thông qua việc tuyển mộ một người dịch gửa bất thật phát từ vùng Trung Á,
2 công dân ngàn hiện mà tuy, và một cư dân khi em đã bị truyền à vì sang nhanh
và một lộ vụ khí, trong quá trình đều tra,
được lợi ăn những tuy giữ một cái mê ra người chàng giới sạch lộ hà,
được chào là tình bị dùng để theo sợ địa điểm một tiêu,
và có khả năng chuyên giữ liệu, giang ngoài lãnh thủng á,
ABSB cũng cho biết, các nghi phạm nếu là người phía u cuối nè thông qua quá sám,
và sức nổ để trình bị chứ vụ tấn công,
thức quan này kánh báo sẵn, những kế hoặc tình tự có thể đã được trình bị tại các khu bự khác,
đồng thời kêu hợp người dân duy trị kánh giác,
chúng họ đồng tình mộ trên mạng sảo hội.